bring in our panel early harold ford jr
former tennessee congressman ceo of
empowerment inclusion capital
molly hemingway senior editor at the
federalist and bill bennett former
education secretary and host of the bill
bennett show podcast bill start with you
you heard jennifer's report and peter
about really
what changed to produce this
announcement that this
investigation is going to move forward
today
well we don't know we don't know what
the president saw i found interesting in
that report by the way some
aggressiveness on the part of the press
have they perhaps heard the
siren call of objectivity now that there
can be aggressive questioning of the
biden administration
if so i hope so look we don't know what
he heard
we do know this much there was a vested
interest on the part of the biden
administration
and denying the truth of anything donald
trump said i mentioned this the other
night the other thing of course is the
stonewalling by
china from the very beginning about what
happened and how this occurred
now it'd be good if the president would
push president xi a little bit
but you just saw in your report that
the white house was reluctant to admit
that any conversation
had taken place let's talk about what we
do know
we do know that they knew they had a
deadly virus
would not let their own people travel
inside their country
but would let them go out and export
this virus to other countries
that doesn't make their culpability uh
look very good uh it makes their
culpability very likely
and i think even opens the possibility
of it being more likely
that they had something to do with the
origins seems to me the burden of proof
is on them
given their behavior once they knew what
it was they were dealing with
however it was created yeah which was
the case
in march of 2020 really i mean that
exact fact pattern
and that exact fact that the u.s
intelligence officials knew
that china was covering it up with
everything they had meantime beijing
today
to quote the wall street journal beijing
meanwhile told an annual gathering of
the world health organization's
decision-making body tuesday that it
considered the investigation
in its country to be complete and set
attention
should now turn to other countries in
other words they're going to launch
their own investigation of where
the coronavirus started molly
switzerland
i think it's not just that the biden
administration
couldn't have donald trump having said
anything true the media really play a
role here too you just pointed out brett
this is what we knew a year ago
and the media thought that there were
two options basically you could blame
china for how they handled this you know
viruses can come from anywhere but how
you handle them is key and there were so
many problems with how
china handled this even if you leave
aside that it was always
a strong possibility that it came out of
this wuhan institute of virology
they couldn't let donald trump or mike
pompeo be right and so they couldn't
even be curious about those origins
this is a massive scandal this is
something that affected the entire world
hundreds of millions of people
you know it destroyed the economy put so
many people out of work
it killed millions of people it sickened
so many people
there should be global focus on just
finding out what happens that it can't
happen again holding people accountable
for what mistakes were made
yesterday biden administration says
they're just going to let woo
the world health organization handle it
we already know that they're too
compromised by china
that's that was part of the problem last
year when they were just taking what
china said and regurgitating it about
how there wasn't human to human
transmission or how you didn't need to
wear masks or how travel bans weren't
necessary
you know we we really need people to
think through
everything here but we already kind of
know what we need to know in terms of
who's culpable
yeah as far as china's transparency take
a listen to this
we have had a terrible failure for 15
months
to recognize as a public and broadly as
a u.s government
the plausibility of the lab leak
possibility
and the huge importance for future
public health and for future national
security
we've gotten this question about the
origins and and uh and we've been pretty
vocal right this administration we've
we didn't have access you know china
wasn't transparent enough
we have been saying that for a very long
time there is no way that the chinese
communist party
is going to turn over any of the
information that would be needed in
order to have a serious investigation
harold some people may ask why is this
important why does it matter
and if china is somehow culpable or
covering up
what was a lab accident from that lab
there are a lot of questions about what
that means retribution was
but then there's the question about how
we've handled it
and we've dismissed it what else are we
dismissing
well it's good to be on with you good
evening i think that it's important for
the investigation to take place and i
agree with some of the things that have
been said already but i think the most
important thing is
as we think about organizing our allies
and partners and even
some around the world who don't
necessarily agree with us all the time
if we're able to get to the bottom of
this with facts and attribute and find
out the origins of how this started
that certainly helps i give dr fauci a
lot of credit for saying
i might have been a little wrong i'm now
wanting to correct that i think we need
more of that
in public life certainly in politics and
i would argue in business
as well and three the 90-day limit that
the president has put around this
whether or not he dismissed this from
the beginning because of politics i i
don't know i doubt that because i know
how serious
an experienced he is in foreign policy
and intelligence matters
but even if you believe there were there
was politics played at the beginning of
this and the president this president
dismissing the investigation because of
his feelings of the former president
you have to give credit for this
administration saying now is the time to
do this right
i don't subscribe to that theory i think
this is the right thing to be doing
and i take president biden at his word
when he was candidate he said from the
outset peter ducey's reporting
pointed out he would have figured out a
way to get into china early on
to figure out what the origins were what
the world needed to be concerned about
and if indeed they had some way to cure
this that they were holding on to
themselves
we'll find that out as this
investigation unfolds i believe bill
last thing i mean we had this media
montage that it was almost a minute
of all these different figures in the
media discounting this calling it a
conspiracy from the very beginning and
and really pointing back to president
trump
final word on this that does have an
effect collectively
on a story like this that now they're
all having to kind of go the other way
uh yeah i don't see a lot of apologies
out there
maya culpa's but they they better sure
go the other way
because as molly pointed out you know we
had a journalist the other night on this
show say
well if china did this on purpose they
got a black eye this isn't a black eye
this was a world catastrophe
uh and uh all attention needs to be
focused here
uh and the press needs to understand the
importance of it
and live up to the standard of that
importance been its own reporting
all right panel thank you we'll see you
a little later in the show hey sean
hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else